it was exactly 65 years ago today that
Elizabeth was crowned queen and few
could have imagined how long the reign
of queen elizabeth ii would last
Jonathan Vigliotti has more on the
longest reigning monarchs storied run On
June 2nd 1953 the United Kingdom and the
world turned on their new television
sets to watch Queen Elizabeth's
coronation CBS broadcast the event from
a hangar at Boston's Logan Airport we
are proud to say that you have just
viewed the first films of the coronation
of Queen Elizabeth the second to be
delivered to the United States and
brought here by CBS technology was a bit
slower those days what developed were
the images of pageantry and tradition
unlike any seen before we were chosen
because we had good figures we were the
right height Lady Anne Glen Connor
walked alongside the Queen as a maid of
honor it was like a production it was
like making a film you know I mean it
was also a coming-out celebration for
the then 27 year old Queen she's had 65
years to master that heavily bejeweled
crown she is both the longest reigning
current monarch and at 92 the oldest in
the world and she still keeps a busy
schedule
she has three engagements over the next
10 days so she's packing it in for 92 no
signs really of slowing down royal
correspondent Roy anika says for a
monarchy often seen as a bit stuffy
Queen Elizabeth assured in an era of
change under the Queen's reign the
monarch has started paying income tax
for the first time she's heralded in the
age of social media to the monarchy
which was very much her doing there have
been leaps and strides in the monarchy
under her watch there's perhaps no
better example of the Queen's leaps and
strides than her evolving royal family
Elizabeth inherited a throne that went
shamed her uncle for wanting to marry an
American divorcee
last month's Royal Wedding of Prince
Harry and American divorcee Megan Markel
was a celebration of love and diversity
and a steady march forward along a path
paved by the Queen for more than six
decades for CBS this morning Saturday
Jonathan Vigliotti London as a fan of
the crown I've followed it all I was
just gonna say she's gotten like this
jolt of life yes cuz of the crowd and
what a fascinating life is yeah